[Music]
well we like to refer to Ely as the
middle of everywhere
just a great place to come and relax
where life seems to move at a little bit
slower of a pace than it does anywhere
else
[Music]
it's less a town but born neighborhood
everybody knows everybody
you can do business on a handshake I
don't think I've had to carry my
driver's license anywhere to cash a
check people know you
that that has a lot of value
the community views education in high
regard the school and education is
really the rallying point for the
community and in our communities we are
not blessed with a with a YMCA with a
bunch of Youth clubs and activities and
those types of things the school
facilities are those facilities
we're sitting in a school that was
originally constructed in 1909
our White Pine Middle School was
originally constructed in 1913. that
school is older than or all four sets of
my grandparents and it's got an amazing
amount of character and spunk and
spirits but it is definitely on its last
legs as far as a school facility goes at
White Pine Middle School I'd say the
biggest issue that we need to deal with
right away is that of accessibility for
some of our students with disabilities
you can see there's stairs like this
with the metal gauge and concrete
throughout the exterior of the White
Pine Middle School but over here
to my left is the only Ada access to
this facility and it come it comes into
the ground floor there is no Ada access
to the other two floors that are in this
facility in order for families and
students with disabilities to access the
office they have to go through the over
this ramp through the library through
the hallway and then gain access to the
office so our most physically challenged
students have the longest path to
Traverse in order to get Services
through the administrative office
we've multiple times had to move those
hallways around to accommodate students
so an entire grade level might move from
second floor to first floor to
accommodate a sixth grade student the
following year when that student's in
the seventh grade we do the seventh
grade down the sixth grade somewhere
else so those movements are definitely
challenging well the main concern from a
facility perspective here at David E
Norman is this is the sprinkling system
and in our Mass Gathering areas where we
have this is the lunchroom all the kids
come here the 300 plus kids come here
for lunch if there were to be a fire
somewhere in the facility there is no
sprinkling system that would extinguish
the fire so it puts the students and
staff somewhat Apparel in the event that
there is some sort of catastrophe here
the cost of reconfiguring some of those
lines it really is cost prohibitive so
in the event of a catastrophic fire it's
it's a real problem that we don't have
that done
[Music]
so here at the White Pine Meadow School
one of our biggest concerns is the
single point of entry into the school as
you can see as you come into this school
you're not met by staff of the school
you can just basically walk in and go
anywhere you want
some of the other concerns is White Pine
Middle School is on a major highway this
is Highway 50 which is right outside
here
traffic goes up and down this roadway
including hazardous materials that goes
to and from our mine site the other is
there's no borders around this there's
no fencing there's no security anybody
can go into any one of these doors if
it's open and they're not regulated or
checked
there's no parking around any of the
campuses people have to park out in the
Avenues we have students being dropped
off when there's two-way traffic going
both ways there's no fencing around our
Middle School campus at all so it's
completely open to anybody I mean
there's a whole host of structural
barriers okay so this is a the tunnel
that goes into our sewer and water
system and part of the steam system that
goes through the school and this is what
a person has to go through if you have
any leaks
well our vision in the school district
is to create world-class learning
conditions for our students
to really meet that mandate that we've
created for ourselves
we need a school that
embodies
that mindset we know that the quality of
the facilities affects learning it
affects attitudes it affects employee
absenteeism so
having a more modern up-to-date facility
would be beneficial to students and
staff in education I've been trying for
over two decades to figure out how do
you raise the money in order to give
these kids what they should have because
having schools that were built prior to
World War one it's not in the best
interest of our kids in education that's
what it's about it's about the kids and
providing them whatever opportunities we
have we need to get rid of those
obstacles and right now the physical
facility itself is an obstacle to equity
in our community
[Music]